you and i tried to sell at a convention
center
oh man is that the most embarrassing
that shows just how little we knew what
was happening with stand-up comedy theo
man that was wild man so i'll i'll start
it so yeah yeah
well josh josh and his
wife who is from lake charles was
putting on
a comedy show and we'd just been on last
comic standing and
they're like hey we can sell some
tickets let's do a show down in lake
charles
you're from louisiana best from
louisiana yeah let's make it happen we
were just on tv
yeah tv must yeah we're gonna sell this
place yeah
so how many seats was it let's look it
up let's pick up the place the lake
charles convention center yeah
i'm dying to know me too hold on before
you hold on let's guess you want guests
yes yeah 15 000
no you think i'm gonna guess
oh you might be right i mean it's a
convention center because cable guy had
just played it
he had wow i'm gonna guess 2600.
75. 7 500. all right
it maybe it seemed like 1500 because we
only sold
can you show a picture from the stage i
wonder if there's any stage view
that's it wow do you remember how many
people were in those seats dude
so i i remember because yes i could see
each one of them
at one point we asked them all to come
down to the front
you remember so we were gonna do radio
right
so we didn't even have radio plant and
the convention center called and they
were like are you guys expecting
a late rush of tickets and i was like
you know
maybe i go why how many do we have sold
because it was the weekend coming up and
they were like we got 179 tickets
and i was like what
and they said yeah and they said we've
brought the curtains as far in as we can
wow but you know what i mean yeah but
you still there's still
4500 seats exposed
and then here's my favorite part of that
besides the fact that we did the show
for probably if there were 150 people
there
i would be excited i don't think there
were no
someone were bought as giveaways i think
so yeah
my favorite part about that theo is that
you know beth
made about 2 000 hats
you remember those hats oh i still got a
box at my house
to i give them away on my lives i love
that but
there is about it just says fairly
normal and because remember we made that
poster
fairly normal comedy tour was that it
yeah yeah yeah we made that po
we made like a fairly normal comedy tour
there's no way there's a poster
that was it that's it right there dude
look at you
wow look at that [ __ ]
august 5th 8 p.m on lake charles this
was
2006. it should have said everybody who
buys one ticket gets the whole row
look at this dude um
oh this is so terrible
why are you third behind flip schultz i
don't know it's just the whole thing's
cringe
it's awesome though i can't i will tell
you man who
who opened the show flip
no no no amy oh yeah amy claire amy
claire
amy claire opened the show because she
was from we thought oh she's from around
here too
that'll help she'll sell a bunch of
tickets none of us could sell anything
or a ticket
uh yeah i mean i think most of them were
you guys as friends and family
all of them yeah it was it was to this
date like
the most humiliating walking out it has
to be the smallest amount of tickets
ever
sold in a large place i can't imagine
there's something smaller 160 tickets in
a
in a convention center yeah in 7 500
seats
and but i will tell you the truth
knowing what stand-up i was doing back
then that's about all it deserved
yeah like i didn't deserve more than 100
people no dude i was telling jokes about
pt cruisers that flippa just bought one
and that was a crazy that was the tough
part of me for the weekend
14 of my jokes were about um
kind of a homoerotic essence of a pt
cruiser car yep
and flip schultz had just gotten one as
like his dream car
or not dream car but he was pretty happy
yeah yeah and he was happy yeah
so it was like oh man we had also just
got through
on the radio the day before we had just
got through
doing about a half an hour rant on his
hands yeah
really on his skinny little fingers and
how oh my god dude it was like
it was pretty crazy and then he flew in
we had a great time but 150 people was
i got a couple of those hats if you want
a man i wouldn't mind a hat i think
god yeah yeah it it's kimberly was 15
years ago 2006.
when do you feel like um i only started
commenting i think in 2003 yeah
when do you feel like like around what
time with your stand-up
because i think it this happens for
everybody where you feel like oh you
really
sunk into it you're like got it well i
thought about this the other day we were
talking about it at the
at the comedy club i was thinking you
know
i always felt like in the beginning of
stand up it feels like
there's like this tide coming in of like
pressure
from the audience you're like okay i
have to get a joke and there's
you know i got to get another joke and
okay there's a laughing but there it's
all like
defensive there's this tide coming in
and you have to like battle it and
battle it
and then eventually over time and you
don't even really notice it
you get up and you don't you're the tide
yeah
so you are putting out the pressure you
are putting out the force
there's nothing coming back in maybe
every
now and then there's a little bit of
like a uh
undercurrent or something of like okay
maybe i should move this along or i'm a
little rusty
but there's it gets to the point where
you're the ocean you're the force
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one